[Music]
so you know i did watch your anime and
review video i think it's been like two
or three weeks ago where you sort of had
like your lineup of things you
recommended watching yeah interesting
because i was like i know i want to
learn about anime yeah i mean i mean
i can't take you seriously
let's plays gantt is like the good one
and i want to hear his thoughts
he's the voice of reason incredible
he's the voice of reason and i thought
if i want to learn about anime yeah
i mean you're already
like you like satoshi khan and akira
yeah i love that that's anime but i mean
just by watching like four films doesn't
make me like into anime but there's a
lot of shows that are like that in the
same vein that i reckon he'd get into
the show i mean there's there's there's
no one there
like i'm not saying it's like exactly
the same or better but like you know
it's in kind of in the same same vibe
yeah it's the same vibe yeah but i i you
know i i feel like i've neglected anime
the reason i don't watch anime just
because growing up i didn't know anyone
that watched it and right there was no
story because they had like a bad
connotation as well to watch anime to be
like a little bit yeah certainly in the
uk i think it's seen as like a very
geeky losery thing i think everywhere
but i don't think that's life
um
but i mean it's a lot different like you
know we've said multiple times like you
know i think when we were growing up
like our age group you'd get bullied for
watching oh [ __ ] yeah yeah but nowadays
you get bullied nowadays kids yeah
probably for breathing
nowadays kids get bullied for not
watching anime yeah not watching certain
things popular
[Laughter]
well based on what i know and like like
goes to the shell accuracy com feed that
into the scenes girls in the show yes of
course you know like the iceberg meme
not the live action
this is the talking
i think he's watching like the the best
of the best
yeah yeah degenerate i think
yeah yeah that's well that's how you get
someone into anime i think you'd really
enjoy baccano
that's like a good entry-level tv series
what happens
okay so it's kind of like hard to
explain like one sentence all right it's
kind of like a quentin tarantino guy
richie film turned into an anime that's
good that's a good synopsis yeah good
little line to get me in yeah actually
any anything anything that the ogre
makes is kind of like that right like
also yeah that was a much like more
exciting description than what he said
about rem and ram and
well no no i don't think you're like
zero i i haven't i have a suspicion you
might not like
they're not even the main characters
this is the funniest thing oh really
yeah who's the main character
bit of something dark some sort of
neo-noir
psychopaths
maybe yeah yeah
everyone says i would like cowboy
beatbox i think you'd like cowboy should
i watch it on netflix
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah i think you really like cowboy
bebop and uh yeah psychopaths i think
that's psychopaths yeah i think you like
psychopaths
yeah yeah
dystopian future where you're rated
based on your mental health score sounds
mental health stability and if you're
like psychotic it just kills you right
yeah so it's kind of like that's pretty
[ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah it's a [ __ ]
up show that's pretty exciting and of
course uh who's going to do the killing
but these enforcers and it's a pretty
harsh story where you follow these
enforcers having to like basically
murder people and uh it's really [ __ ]
cool yeah it's really easy
it's
they have this gun right they have this
gun uh and you point at the person and
the gun scans what their mental health
is and if they're meant to identify
their mental yeah if they're mental that
the gun goes from just you know stun gun
to just obliterating a person to like to
their atoms based on how bad their
mental health is not called against like
annihilators dominating almost like a
future where the dislike button was
never hidden then
because now it's gone my mental health
is so much better on youtube
but that's that's that's a cool premise
yeah it's a very cool phrase
psycho pass psychopaths i actually think
you would enjoy that actually because if
you're a psychopath
is that i think i think it's more the
opposite if you're a cycle you don't
die psycho psycho dog
literally holden
out the times now you help me help me
get you you should start titling anime
psycho die ram and ram yeah remin ram
and ram all right i'll get into i'll
probably enjoy it more than a new matrix
that you were talking about i feel like
yeah yeah it's more into general like
films right and yeah and cinematography
and staying up with the news and stuff
but i think a lot of the best
cinematography comes out of anime films
just watching acura the other day i was
like holy [ __ ] the cinematography this
year oh yeah it's brilliant the best of
the best 10 out of 10. so i kind of want
to go down the anime rabbit hole yeah i
mean like do you explore them a bit more
do you still like look at films the same
way now or do you focus more on like
cinematography and just
the general filmmaking craft i still
think i do look at cinematography a lot
but i still think story is really
important like i just watched the matrix
four yeah uh resurrections and it was
all right it's very meta it kind of
comments on itself a lot and uh i
recommend watching it
but it's there's no sort of replay value
i asked myself a film is good
is it if a film is good i want to
rewatch it yeah yeah if i don't want to
re-watch it i can't even say re-watch it
if i don't want to re-watch it then it's
it's not overly great
i think you'd like one punch man weirdly
enough one punch man i think he'd like
it i don't know i think he'd like it
really i think so i think anyone can
enjoy one point i think he'd i think
he'd find it amusing
yeah and i'd too fair the cinematography
is saying but there's a point but i
think there'll come a point where he'll
watch paul and punch man and be like oh
this joke again
i mean i think i think you'd enjoy it i
don't think it would be like your
favorite most favorite animal right all
the time satoshi kum it's nice
there is no stage
what did you [ __ ] stick you in a
crane game machine
it's it's good like popcorn
entertainment yeah
because i remember this weekend i saw i
finally saw dune yeah not in cinemas
unfortunately so i didn't i didn't oh no
i didn't feel the subwoofers
you didn't feel the voice oh my god like
even
watching it on my tv i felt like like i
felt like it was getting bass out of the
tv that just didn't exist man well i
think i i don't know how it was like a
sub woofer wasn't that great 300 tv i
know if you have the same one that would
not work i watched that imax i nearly
cried it was like ears like bleeding
like han zimmer but like that was pretty
good but i got like the cinematography
and that was [ __ ] insane dude
one is as good if dune two comes out and
if it's good it's coming out right yeah
i mean is it gonna be good i mean the
doom one was amazing if doing two is
good because like it was weird because
it didn't feel like i was watching a
movie it felt like i was watching uh hbo
tv series something like that i did like
when it ended it felt like it was an end
of an episode rather than just an end of
a movie right but it wasn't necessarily
but i don't really like the ending and i
hate
oh i don't know if it spoils it just for
saying the last line the film when she's
like this is just the
that's beginning there's a storm coming
that's sort of like [ __ ] line you've
seen so many films i mean to be fair
it's based on the 60s boxing yeah
seven eight out of 10.
how much seven eight out of 10.
8.5 i'd give it like an eight or nine
because the story just picks up from
there as well like if you wrote the
books but yeah i mean i'm looking for it
was just like my kind of story where it
just set up the world really well i was
more interested like i i watched i
watched the film and then i just went on
the binge of just lore explanation
videos because i'm just like there are
so many interesting aspects of this
world that they just kind of didn't have
time to explore yeah frank herbert was
nuts dude i don't know how he did it
yeah well it's it's like how old's the
book now like [ __ ] well first book
was 1964.
yeah
could i spoil one thing in it could we
do a spoiler warning
one thing i really didn't like about the
film is that they had this really uh
so again spoilers please please watch
dune please if you haven't um this is
really uh supposed to be especially like
a really impactful scene where he kills
someone oh the first time i was very
good but then like it's supposed to be a
really big deal but they just like bring
it up like one second before he kills
someone for the first time they're like
by the way he's never killed anyone stop
stabbing a man to death and it's like oh
don't really think that was that
difficult
it's yeah it's about to climb
like built it up from the start so that
i think that's the only way i've had
it's a strange feeling because the big
set pieces happen sort of halfway
through rather than at the end yeah and
i felt a little bit i'm all for changing
up the sort of story and doing something
a little bit original but yeah i felt
like the payoff of the ending was like
oh well i don't think you think it
needed a big set piece that wasn't the
highlight for me because actually i was
so immersed in the world that when it
went to the big set piece i was like can
we just go back to doing like small [ __ ]
yeah i just i just oh yeah i love that
yeah political the political aspect was
really yeah yeah
one of those films that i was like bored
for the first 40 minutes and then
after i had kind of sat through all the
good stuff i was like actually now i
want more of the starting start board
more talking i wonder that's why when
you're making it is it is it hard to see
it from a perspective of someone who
doesn't know anything about the law of
dune how do you do it when you already
know so much about and you know how good
the law is and how do you explain it in
a way that's engaging because i do think
i don't know if you were but i was bored
for the first 40 minutes just waiting
for something to happen oh i was no i
wasn't yeah the
world was pretty engrossing yeah yeah it
kind of reminded me of uh gonna mention
it again joey arcane where the first the
first two episodes nothing really
technically i want chris to watch that
actually he'd love it what's that about
oh you should summarize that
if you're gonna if you go to that side
i'm
[Applause]
legitimately want someone to make one of
those things where it's like it's been
blank days since arcane was mentioned i
just rip it off every week it's amazing
amazing amazing [ __ ] i haven't seen it
yeah yeah amazing wasn't it like one of
the top shows of imdb what's it about
how would you explain it you're clearly
familiar with that one in one sentence
legal agency against one sentence uh
there's no way i can just disclose
describing one sentence it's just a very
engrossing world that's kind of
kind of like say what it is it's league
of legends it's league of legends it's
based off of the game
not really no no no no i know i know i
know raid of shadows again
it's not it's not just give it a watch
give it a chance the animation is insane